Oh, oh, I think it's loud.
I'm testing audio.
Hello.
This is okay.
I sound muffled.
How?
Hold on.
Let me take this thing off.
I'm holding my mic.
Like I'm at real karaoke.
Minto Stinko.
Motorboat is clear.
Where's brain rot?
Oh my gosh.
I leave.
I leave and...
The world turns to Uma Musume.
The world is obsessed with horse now.
It's kind of crazy.
Everybody... I was like, where have you guys been?
For the horse.
I've always been here, Minto.
At the horse derby.
If only... If only... I were a horse?
Would you bet on me?
Be honest.
Would you go all in?
Did you hear the English version of Uma Pyoidensutsu?
I saw that it exists.
And that... Satohina sings in it too.
And...
But I bookmarked it.
I haven't listened to it yet.
No.
I'm getting glued.
Don't... Don't turn me into glue.
So for those... Sorry.
I should back up a little bit.
First, thank you everybody for... The donuts.
Thank you.
And... Uh... Sorry.
It's been a minute.
Um... It's... Uh... I've been really busy.
But... Um... Uh... Today!
Well... Today, I have... If you are at the... Um... Anime Expo area... Um... Which... If you are, it's very early.
Go to sleep.
Um... Um... I will be performing at... Fantastic Reality.
And I'm nervous.
So I wanna do karaoke.
To kind of... Get these nerves out, you know?
Wait, hold on.
Let me fix something real quick.
Wah!
Hey, we're the 50 gifted!
And... Um... Uh... Think of it as like a... Warm up for my voice.
Run!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Oh my gosh, you guys!
Thank you!
Murr!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
I... Uh... I... Uh...
I... Uh...
Um... Um... Um...
Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um... Um I'll do the thing I need to do.
I'll come back.
I'll sleep too.
Stop apologizing.
Call me Canadian.
It's not real, but you could call me that.
But, I will be back to normal stream stream.
Uh, yeah, very soon.
But, before then, there's a few more fun things that I must do.
So, we are on the lookout.
Yeah, ooh.
I got a healthy... what is this?
Some sort of tea.
Toasty.
They're working super hard.
Thank you.
I'm trying.
I know that everything right now is so...
No jelly?
What percent jelly are you?
I have jelly!
Hold on, let me go grab it.
Hold on.
Oh, I had it next to me the whole time.
I brought it over here.
I completely forgot.
My jelly.
I'm probably like...
200% jelly.
For those who don't know, I love cognac jelly.
And, um...
I love cognac jelly!
And, I eat it a lot.
And, I become jelly.
Oh my gosh, though, you guys.
What flavor is it?
It's grape.
Budou味.
I, um...
Another thing, too.
That I wanted to talk about.
Why it's hard for me to stream.
Is...
I am a ghost.
It doesn't...
Does not go outside.
And...
The heat...
Has completely...
I have...
You could call it...
You could call it an allergy to the sun, basically.
Hehehehe.
And...
Um...
It completely...
Makes me...
It dries up all my ectoplasm.
And because...
I haven't been streaming...
I am basically...
A wisp like you guys.
I have no...
I have...
I have not been haunting...
And collecting...
Your life energy, so...
As much.
So I...
I...
I am...
I am so weak.
That's why you guys have to watch my streams.
Or else I...
I was like...
You know that thing...
Where if you don't believe in fairies...
They...
They die?
I learned that from Peter Pan.
For me...
If I don't stream and collect your life energy...
Then I...
I will...
I will become...
Just a little...
Will-o-wisp.
Now we know.
It's true.
How do you know so much about fairies?
Cause of Peter Pan.
So how can you thank you so much for the pink?
Thank you.
Like I said, I know that right now...
Things are very...
Mysterious.
And I...
Am busy, but I cannot talk about it.
And it's frustrating just as much for me...
As it is for...
Maybe you guys.
So...
I try to drop little hints.
Wink, wonk.
Here and there.
So...
And sometimes they're not even hints.
Sometimes it's just me being like...
Oh yeah baby.
This thing's coming and I'm working on it.
But uh...
Good kind of busy hopefully.
Mmhmm.
There's a couple things coming up that I...
Very...
Very soon.
That I think...
You guys will...
Like a lot.
What?
I think so.
That you guys will be...
Like...
Wah!
Very, very soon.
Very soon.
Mmhmm.
So...
That implies...
We stopped believing in you.
Don't stop.
Believing.
How dare you be secretive about projects.
You have been asked to keep secret, you monster.
I am a monster.
Konbama.
Hmm.
So...
Yeah.
Spirit bombing you some energy.
Do the...
Lift your arms into the air.
Viking.
Dragon Ball.
Send me energy.
Or I'll just...
I'll just suck it right out of you.
Like I'm gonna do this...
Uh...
This jelly right here.
Nom, nom.
I'm glad that's enough jelly for now.
Even though I want more.
Oh my gosh!
I forgot!
I promised...
On Twitter if you saw it.
I said I would give some sloppy kisses.
Come here.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'll put away these bad boys.
Oh!
That's not the right number.
That's not the number.
Wait.
Is it the right number?
Yep.
Okay.
I think my thing's all messed up.
Whatever.
Uh-uh-uh...
Okay.
Chibi Mito coming in hot.
Newy!
Minty Fresh.
It should be... a little jelly-like, actually.
Odd time to join the stream.
Welcome in.
Shall we sing?
I don't know what to sing.
I did this on such a... impromptu.
I did this so impromptu that I don't even...
I don't even have a reverb.
Um, by the way, it's just gonna be English songs, cause I...
I'm lazy.
All I have is karaoke fun.
Maybe karaoke is a bad idea.
Hold on, let me get a voicemint.
Where?
Oh, they're over there.
One second.
One second, one second.
I will eat this.
And then...
I shall sing some songs.
Just a couple.
Like I said.
It's not like I missed you guys or anything.
That's why I give you big sloppy kisses and I...
Why isn't this coming out?
I...
Stream at odd times.
...
Just to talk to you and see you.
Why isn't this coming out?
Hehehe.
Hm.
I eat my voicemap.
Dust Goal!
I miss you.
How's the volume, by the way?
Am I loud enough?
I can't hear myself.
I miss having monitoring.
I want to go home.
Quiet.
Let me try.
Also, I don't have a noise gate.
I'm sorry.
How's that?
Peeking?
Dark things.
What is that?
Better?
Good?
Yeah.
Old Town Road.
Like the... Like the... I'mma take you to the Old Town Road.
What?
Yes.
Little Nas X.
What?
Huh?
No.
Currently, I work with only 20% energy.
Oh no!
I literally give you all my energy.
Don't give me all your energy.
I need you alive.
So that...
I can keep stealing your life energy.
I'll take it to like 1%.
And then you build it back up.
Well, be glad you have.
Are you doing song requests?
I don't know.
Okay, Doki.
Sure.
Hit me.
Hit me with your song request.
Go for it.
I'm ready.
Oh, B12?
Shot B12.
Be kind to your pipes with song selection.
I know.
Thank you.
Nah.
Shot B12.
I actually love American Dad.
So like... When I saw that, I was like...
Oh damn.
I wonder if they have it on here.
B12.
Oop.
Let me search American Dad.
Oh.
I'm getting like... American Pie.
American Boy.
American Girl.
American Idiot.
American Soldier.
American Honey.
American Kids.
American Pie Again.
American Woman.
American Teenager.
American Toothan.
Toon, American women... lots of American women... American music, American Honky Tonk Bar Association, American Pie again...
Oh gosh, you can like... you can like hear me slapping my knee.
I don't have pants on.
I'm wearing my dress.
I'm just slapping my leg.
Doki asked for Mickey Mouse Clubhouse.
Did she?
Wait, I missed it.
Not even my song request.
Wait, hold on.
I'm double checking if that's what you wanted, Doki.
Mickey Mouse.
Is it because of the music?
I picked it.
Because it was kind of...
stupid sounding.
Oh, did I just shrink the screen?
Yes, I did.
Sorry.
Yeah, okay.
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse.
Actually, how does this go?
I guess we'll figure it out together.
Okay.
Let's do Mickey Mouse together.
Actually, I don't know how this goes.
They may be...
Wait, they might be Giants?
Miska.
Mickey Mouse.
I think it's so loud.
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E.
That's me.
Mouse.
It's the Mickey Mouse Clubhouse.
Come inside, it's fun inside.
Roll call!
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E.
Oh, that's it.
Yay!
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E.
The ominous ending.
What do you mean I missed the best part?
Scammed?
What do you mean?
That's all they got on here.
Oh, wait.
There's...
Wait.
There's the Mickey Mouse Club.
Let me see if this is better.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Weep, weep, weep.
Who's the leader of the club that's made for you and me?
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E.
Hi there, hi there.
Oh, there's a wish you could be.
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-I-C.
Mickey Mouse.
What?
Come along and sing this song and join the Danmarine.
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-I-C.
Mickey Mouse Club.
We'll have fun.
We'll meet new faces.
We'll do things and we'll go places.
All around the world we're marching.
Donald Duck is who that was supposed to be.
Yeah, why is Donald Duck shot shot?
That's what I heard too.
Who's the leader of the club that's meant for you and me?
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E.
Hi there, hi, ho there.
You're as long as the best can be.
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E.
Mickey Mouse.
Donald Duck.
Forever a little solo and a ho, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Come along and sing this song and join the Danmarine.
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E.
Here's the continue to bun.
What is happening?
What's going on?
Yay!
For now it's time to say goodbye to all our company.
We're going to die!
M-I-C-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E-Y.
We like ya.
This is what they sing when they lower you into the coffin.
Wait, I have to play the Donald Duck part again.
It's so out of the field.
Here, I'm even gonna change it.
Absolute cinema.
Sorry, it's a little slow to load because of the Wi-Fi.
Minky Mouse.
Cheers to my job.
Thanks for the karaoke.
Thanks, Doki!
See you later.
Hello, is it gonna load?
Oh!
Uh...
Are we back?
Welcome back?
We're live?
We're good?
Okay.
Hold on, let me try to...
Pressing this again.
The Wi-Fi here is like...
It just sometimes...
Like, poops itself.
It's kind of...
It's kind of like the worst Wi-Fi I've had in a hotel before.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
It was about here.
M-U-C.
Oh, wait.
We need this.
M-U-C.
Minky Mouse!
You guys' comments are killing me.
I'm already dead.
If I wasn't already dead, you guys would kill me again.
Maybe we don't do Disney.
Oh my goodness.
Sorry, the Wi-Fi is so bad.
I'm glad it lasted for the collab the other day, no?
Oh, goodness gracious.
Minky Mouse and Ducky Duck.
One more time, one more time, for old times' sake.
Me when I lie on my resume.
This guy is just like, oh yeah, I can do a Donald Duck impression.
Oh
gosh.
Oh, it's so...
This is so funny.
Oh goodness gracious.
That was what I needed.
Holy moly.
Wait, what was the other one?
It was over here, I think.
Here, here.
Oh my god.
What is he saying?
He's supposed to be saying Donald Duck.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm in literal tears right now.
Let's think something else.
Well, shall we?
Oh, I can't watch that.
I can't listen to it again.
I will go to...
I will...
I will cease to exist.
We have a danger!
Happy birthday!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
One last time, please, and I'll just watch the VOD.
Watch the VOD.
Okay.
Alright.
What shall we sing?
Now I'm like...
Do we goofy?
Hmm.
Oh.
Just realized the names are normal again.
You're right!
I wish they would fix the comments.
Like, when people comment on my videos, they also are like the ats.
And it's hard to...
If I don't recognize your profile picture...
Or if your at is...
Unless your at is the same as...
Your...
Your username...
It's...
So annoying.
She doesn't recognize us.
Another YouTube moment.
It makes no sense.
Makes no sense.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm gonna go to like...
Not my favorites.
Let's see.
Um...
Ah...
Well, let's see.
Um...
Let's enter jazz.
Oh.
Wait a second.
Oh, I accidentally clicked love songs instead.
But we could do this one.
We could do this one.
You don't like jazz?
Never knew why they added ats.
Me neither.
I don't get it.
Oh.
Some of these...
Uh...
Some of these jazzy songs...
I will save for...
For what my voice is...
I'm not even really supposed to be doing karaoke right now.
But...
I was like...
I need something to just kind of like...
Release my emotions.
You know?
Wait...
I don't know.
Anyway.
Let's do...
Let's do this one.
You know what?
I can do this one.
Wait.
Hold on.
Uh...
This one just showed up.
Oh, okay.
It was the right one.
Okay.
I'll try it.
Don't worry.
It's not hurting my throat.
I don't know.
Somewhere...
Beyond the sea...
Waiting for me...
My lover stands on golden sea...
And watches the ships...
Black coast sailing...
Somewhere...
Beyond the sea, she's there watching for me.
If I could fly like birds on high, then straight to her arms I'd go sailing.
It's far.
Wait.
Beyond the stars.
It's near.
Beyond the moon.
I know.
Oh gosh, it's going to get really high though for me.
Without a doubt.
My heart will leave me there soon.
Well, me.
Beyond the shore, we'll kiss just as before.
Happy we'll be beyond the sea.
Then never again, I'll go sailing.
I know.
Beyond the doubt.
Oh, my heart will leave me there soon.
We'll meet.
I know we'll meet.
Beyond the shore.
We'll kiss just as before.
Happy we'll be beyond the sea.
And never again, I'll go sailing.
No more sailing.
So long, sailing.
Bye-bye, sailing.
Move on now, captain.
Have you ever played Bioshock?
I haven't.
Oh no!
No!
No more Mickey Mouse!
No more... No!
Please let me... Okay.
Sorry.
Sorry for that.
Finding Minto.
Let me take a sip of my tea.
Give us Donald!
I gotta get back to work.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Um... Let's go, uh, here.
I kinda want more, like, goofy songs that I can...
Just kinda be, like, silly, you know?
I'm getting sleepy too.
I gotta rest up.
For the concert!
Scary.
Scary!
Oh my gosh.
Let's see.
What's another song we could do?
What's another song?
What's under pop?
Wait, my chat froze.
Oh, do you think...
Well, how stereotypical YouTube...
Eh?
Eh... Eh?
Break stuff, oh, yeah.
Hahahaha!
B12!
They don't have it!
Shot B12!
Let me... Oh!
Wait!
There we go.
You guys are back.
Okay.
A thousand miles.
Yeah, we can do that.
A thousand... miles... Spooky Scary Skeletons!
I'll do that one after... Time after time.
Okay, I can do that.
Crepe by RabioHead.
Why is this not loading?
Gosh, it's... Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Okay, Spooky Scary Skeletons.
I'll add that to the queue.
Crepe.
Oh!
Wait.
Am I... I am back?
I am?
We're back?
Hold on.
Nothing is loading.
There we go.
This is, yeah, terrible.
I'm gone!
I'm a creep.
Crepe.
I'm a desert.
I'm filled with strawberries, bananas, and whipped cream.
Hmm...